bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero el
rechazo al gobierno de Dina boluarte ha
hecho que miles de personas salgan a la
calle a protestar durante las últimas
semanas en Perú una situación convulsa
que ha paralizado a la nación andina y
que ha dejado decenas de muertes en
medio de rechazos por la violencia
policial esta profunda crisis deriva de
años de polarización política
ingobernabilidad dimisiones y casos de
corrupción que han afectado a toda la
clase política cuestiones que han
generado que desde el comienzo de siglo
haya habido 11 presidentes
para comprender mejor esta situación
toca remontarse a noviembre del año 2000
Alberto fujimori llevaba 10 años en el
poder y había sido reelegido para un
tercer mandato este expresidente obtuvo
un gran poder tras un autogolpe en 1992
y su gobierno se caracterizó por tener
tintes autoritarios y atentar contra
múltiples derechos humanos Aunque el 21
de noviembre del año 2000 se vio
obligada a dimitir por casos de
corrupción y huyó a Japón
su gestión hizo que millones de personas
lo apoyasen por su éxito económico y su
lucha contra las guerrillas de sendero
luminoso pero también tuvo millones de
detractores por su autoritarismo una
polarización que dividiría al país
durante las siguientes décadas tras
fujimori Perú vivió un proceso de
florecimiento democrático y de relativa
estabilidad en el que llegaron al poder
Alejandro Toledo entre el 2001 y el 2006
Alan García entre el 2006 y el 2011 y
llanta humala entre 2011 y 2016 sin
embargo durante el mandato de humala fue
cuando estalló el caso odebrecht una
constructora brasileña que financiaba
campañas políticas en América Latina a
cambio de concesiones para Obras
Públicas esta trama salpicó al propio
humala y lo llevó a prisión pero también
al expresidente Alejandro Toledo que
actualmente está prófugo y a la espera
de ser extraditado por Estados Unidos y
al expresidente Alan García que durante
su investigación se suicidó en abril de
a estos casos hay que sumar el de
Alberto fujimori que fue detenido en
2007 y está recluido en prisión por
delitos de lesa humanidad corrupción y
espionaje entre otros los 10 años de
gobierno de fujimori generaron un gran
rechazo pero el fujimorismo no murió
continuó con sus aspiraciones de Volver
al poder a través de su hija keiko
fujimori quien fue candidata en
2011-2016 y 2021 El Fuerte anti
fujimorismo evitó que ganara esos
comicios Pero ha sido incapaz de llegar
a consensos debido a su enorme
heterogeneidad política algo que ha
creado presidentes extremadamente
débiles y es base de la crisis actual
por ejemplo en 2016 Pedro Pablo
kuczynski tuvo que soportar años de
inestabilidad por culpa de un parlamento
en el que se impidió en todo momento que
este economista limeño gobernara una
situación que empeoró después de que se
le relacionara también con casos de
corrupción como odebrecht algo que llevó
a su dimisión en marzo de 2018
esta confrontación política ha creado un
clima de ingobernabilidad pienso que lo
mejor para el país es que yo renuncie a
la presidencia de la República su
sucesor fue el vicepresidente Martín
vizcarra quien siguió enfrentada al
congreso vizcarra se encontró con
reiterados intentos de obstaculizar su
acción de gobierno a través del órgano
legislativo el expresidente de hecho
llegó a sufrir dos mociones de vacancia
por incapacidad moral un concepto
arcaico y abstracto que en un origen
hacía referencia a que el presidente
sufriera una enfermedad mental pero que
el congreso peruano comenzó a usar de
forma reiterada para intentar acabar con
el mandatario la primera fracasó pero la
segunda en noviembre de 2020 triunfó El
Congreso de la República ha votado por
la vacancia presidencial como dije al
concluir mi discurso de la mañana
la historia
y el pueblo peruano
juzgarán
las decisiones que cada quien toma tras
vizcarra pero atravesó un período de
profunda inestabilidad en el que vivió
dos presidentes en apenas unos meses una
crisis institucional que no tenía
precedentes hasta la fecha
Manuel Merino no estuvo en el cargo ni
una semana debido a las protestas que
generó su nombramiento y Francisco
sagasti fue el encargado de dirigir al
país hasta las elecciones de abril de
2021 y los comicios no fueron mucho
mejor casi 20 candidatos se presentaron
a la primera vuelta sin que ninguno de
ellos obtuviera un porcentaje de Voto
representativo de hecho el ganador de la
primera vuelta Pedro Castillo obtuvo
solo el 18,9% de votos sin embargo al
enfrentarse en segunda vuelta con keiko
fujimori pudo obtener la victoria
gracias al rechazo que hay hacia ella
pero esta Victoria no trajo ninguna
solución Castillo se vio incapaz de
gobernar al enfrentarse a un congreso
profundamente fragmentado que abrió
varias investigaciones en su contra por
corrupción le prohibió salir del país y
llegó a presentar tres mociones de
vacancia por incapacidad moral de las
cuales solo triunfó la última después de
que Castillo intentara disolver el
congreso en un gesto que se interpretó
como un autogolpe de estado fallido que
llevó al poder a Dina boluarte
algo que ha empeorado aún más una
situación de crisis profunda que viene
desde hace años y lo más preocupante es
que se desconoce si puede haber una
solución a un problema que es más
estructural que coyuntural y que podría
afectar incluso a un campo que Hasta
ahora ha permanecido fuerte como el
económico una combinación explosiva que
puede ser peligrosa para Perú
con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]